[Musik]
ja willkommen zu einer neuen viera cast
podcast folge jörg schaefers listhalle
masse jetzt hatten wir eine folge über
ästhetik und ganz viel darüber geredet
über über so dass das dass das digitale
eine neue raum zeitlichkeit hat eine
ganz neue logik ich frag mich halt jetzt
auch in bezug auf die folgen über
ästhetik da ging es ja um gegenstände
und das wird mit denen das die sich
verändern und so was aber hatten die
digitalität oder digitale umfelder haben
die dann auch einfluss auf das wir
handeln können und da kann ich jetzt
alles machen was ich will weil das ist
ja toll mit der so ist das zeitlose
traumlos die sachen speichern
eine ganze gespeicherte ist ja
eigentlich ein freies sandkasten in dem
ich tolle burgen bauen kann und das tun
kann was ich möchte
siehst du das auch so da bist du ja es
ist ein ganz spannendes thema weil wir
von der ontologie der digitalität
verwiesen werden auf die ethik der
digitalität wir haben jetzt sehr viel
geredet über virtuelle realitäten über
entitäten also über den blauen party hat
worüber wir nicht so viel geredet haben
sind virtuelle realitäten die handlungen
bezeichnet
also wir können im internet natürlich
auch handeln aber welchen unter
logischen status haben diese handlungen
wenn sie virtuell realisiert sind und
wie ich ihn normativ ethischen status
haben sie können wir im internet alles
tun oder geld nicht dort auch gewisse
regeln für unser virtuelles handeln und
das ist glaube ich der punkt wo wir als
philosophin und philosophen uns genauere
gedanken machen müssen wir müssen
letztendlich eine ethik der
digitalisierung oder wie ich noch er
finde eine ethik der digitalität
entwickeln da gibt es ja zufällig schon
einen vorschlag der von europäischen
union so zur zur zur diskussion
vorgebracht wurde das heißt also kann
man unter digital kater punkt eu
nachschlagens die kater der digitalen
grundrechte von der europäischen union
was hältst du davon also das ist ein
guter vorschlag ist man erster schritt
über dieses neue fehlt dieses ethische
fällt sich zu verständigen
ich mach oben rechts sitzen link reinste
unsere themen sind und wo wird er im
seminar ausführlich darauf eingegangen
sind
da werden einige artikel präsentiert und
da können wir uns zweimal herausgreifen
also zwei grundrechte die gefordert
werden im digitalen zeitalter
ja wir hatten ja eben war ja die frage
nach freiheit
da steht artikel 2 freiheit jeder hat
ein recht auf freie information und
kommunikation
dieses recht ist konstitutiv für die
freie gesellschaft
zusätzlich steht dort aber auch es
beinhaltet das recht auf nichtwissen das
bedeutet im prinzip es gibt einen haufen
an informationen im internet über alles
mögliche und auch viele über auch paar
sinnvolle dinge und die der artikel sagt
eben ich ich hätte ja auch die freiheit
mich nicht zu informieren und unwissen
zu bleiben
genau das finde ich an sich ist ja ist
ja sozusagen bezieht sich das
wahrscheinlich auch so eine situation
man ist vor gericht man hat irgendwas
gemacht oder nicht gemacht und dann
würde gefragt ja warum also warum haben
sie gemacht so ist gibt ja hier fakten
und informationen darüber dass man
eigentlich man hätte sich informieren
können warum so und jetzt ist die frage
ist die person die da ist ist die
schuldig oder nicht
das wäre so ein fall wo es dann um
fahrlässigkeit gingen also die intuition
die du jetzt da formulierten die ich
auch teile wenn ich dich recht
verstanden habe ist die das ist
eigentlich gibt es kein recht auf
nichtwissen würde so ein bisschen aus
dann punkt folgen mal vor gericht
müssten wir uns rechtfertigen darin dass
wir es nicht wissen wollten oder wissen
konnten oder wie auch immer also ich
sehe ich habe da noch nicht so eine
klare meinung weil für mich ist das
sozusagen unklar wann ist die
problematik bus hervor in einer gerichts
situation ja jemand im vor gericht ist
es ziemlich klar da gibt es dann den
vorwurf der fahrlässigkeit du hättest
das wissen müssen als mündiger bürger
als mündige bürgerin
hier ist es ja noch viel breiter gefasst
hier geht es ja nicht nur um juristisch
relevantes wissen so geht's einfach um
alltagswissen um die schiere
informationsflut die du auch benannt
hass und luciano florida spricht hier
von der info sphären also big data ist
ein weiterer wichtiger begriff die
informationsflut nimmt dermaßen überhand
dass wir ohne den einsatz von
algorithmen das ist ja diese algorithmen
zieht bei felix stalder ich nach oben
rechts ein interview zwischen die und
völlig streitereien oder diese
algorithmen zieht also diese
verarbeitung dieser information diese
kürzung dieser stützung gar nicht mehr
uns orientieren können im internet weil
es einfach zu viele informationsflut
gibt aber selbst das wenige was dann zu
uns dringt durch diese algorithmen
gefehlt hat selbst das ist noch zu viel
und das problem des internets ist das
dass wir häufig nicht richtig das
internet nicht gewichtet was jetzt
wichtiger und weniger wichtig ist da ist
kein interner relevanz mechanismus am
werk sondern das müssen wir selbst
übernehmen stichwort medienkompetenz und
ich glaube dieser artikel meint einfach
angesichts dieser datenflut müssen wir
uns nicht allem aussetzen
wir dürfen uns auch verschließen ich
sehe es trotzdem ein bisschen kritisch
also meine persönliche meinung ist es
gibt kein recht auf nicht wissen oder
nur sehr begrenzt ist sondern wer das
angebot des internets hat der muss es
auch nutzen aktiv aber eben und das ist
vielleicht die modifikation er muss es
kompetent medien kompetent nutzen
also ich würde sagen jetzt hier von den
rechten mal den pflichten es gibt die
pflicht zur medienkompetenz
das ist glaube ich das entscheidende
jeder muss kritisch alle informationen
prüfen und wissen wir an verschiedenen
quellen zu verschiedenen formationen
kommt und die dann vergleichen auf ihre
güte hin
man kann jetzt nicht einfach irgendein
ihm aus dem internet zitieren so wie ich
es gemacht haben im letzten video über
sexualität
ja klar also ich meine dass jede
information ist wichtig eben immer nur
aus einem bestimmten gesichtspunkt es
gibt nur sehr wenige informationen die
generell von bedeutung sind sondern je
nach kontext je nach interesse wird eine
zum einen informationen plötzlich ganz
wichtig und nach einem
perspektivenwechsel eben nicht mehr
und das ist glaube ich dass spezifische
wir sollten nicht alle informationen
gleich behandeln haben wir hier noch
einen zweiten artikel wieder auf denen
wir eigentlich wollten der artikel
nummer acht sein recht auf vergessen
werden dass steht jeder mensch hat das
recht auf digitalen neuanfang
dieses recht findet seine grenzen in den
berechtigten informationsinteresse der
öffentlichkeit wie siehst du das ja so
das spricht eine ganz zentrale
problematik der digitalität an nämlich
das problem dass im internet daten
prinzipiell immer gespeichert werden
können zwar und zwar deswegen weil wie
ich mich immer wieder wiederhole
informationen oder fußstapfen im
internet nicht raum zeitlich festgelegt
sind sondern eben auf eine andere weise
existieren als unsere physikalische
realität wo ist denn jetzt dieses datum
bitte schön zu finden wo existiert jetzt
dieses diese informationen existiert sie
auf diesem pc im internet ja
offensichtlich nicht auf dem server
vielleicht aber im internet ist ja alles
vernetzt heißt irgendwie überall oder
auch nicht und es ist ein ethisches
problem deswegen weil wir das phänomen
der verjährung kennen das macht das die
zeit die wunden heilt oder auch
vergebung also die zeit ist ein faktor
der die schuld jetzt vielleicht nicht
direkt vernichtet oder die schuld sage
ich jetzt mal nimmt uns aber die doch
eine gewisse heilungs funktion hat und
das vergessen werden trägt auch dazu bei
dass wir uns wieder auf neues auf die
zukunft besinnen können und das
vergangene vergangen sein lassen und
nach vorne blicken und wenn wir eben
jetzt diese phänomene haben dass wir
alle informationen auch lang vergangene
nicht mehr aktuelle informationen immer
wieder aktualisieren können
reproduzieren können dann haben wir
irgendwann das problem dass wir nicht
mehr vergessen können also die internet
fakten die daten tragen nur selten in
zeitlichen index ich kann jede wieder
auf dem bildschirm
holen und sie vergilbt nicht weil sie
irgendwie schon zehn jahre alt ist ist
genauso in schwarz und weiß oder wie
auch immer
wie jede aktuellere version das heißt
internetdaten haben nicht den index
derzeit gelten alle wie ich seit
atopische präsentismus sie gelten alle
gleich sind
man hört manchmal dass das eben dann das
internet doch sehr schnell vergisst und
zwar wenn irgendein blog geupdatet würde
eine seite aktualisiert wird
verschwinden auf einmal inhalte und
informationen
würdest du das aber ausschließen aus
dieser aussage weil man sozusagen so
immer auf die möglichkeit hin weiß dass
man es irgendwie trotzdem bekommt genau
das wäre sollte jetzt die problematik
auf dich abziehen würde
natürlich gibt es das internet ist
schnelllebiger geworden viele dinge
verschwinden
aber sie sind dennoch präsent sie werden
eben nicht mehr gesucht oder von google
vorne gelenkt ist dann eben auf seite 20
und will klickt sich schon bis heute 20
durch bei google suchergebnissen ja aber
es ist da und wenn ich nur direkt danach
suche nach diesem spezifischen datum
dann kriege ich es auch wieder ganz
aktuell angezeigt und dann gibt es
internet kvf dort horkheim beck
maschinen hat kann ich eben alle auch
bislang auch wieder gelöschte homepages
internetseiten wiederherstellen und zwar
nach bestimmten speicherung punkten vor
zehn zwanzig dreißig jahren das
besonders peinlich wenn man selbst mal
eine homepage erstellt hatte vor 20
jahren
und dann wieder sieht wie die jedoch
damals recht aus heutiger sicht jetzt
antiquiert und ich glaube das ist die
problematik hast du irgendwie sozusagen
noch einen punkt mit dem du ja mit dem
gut sozusagen eine eine normative
aussage die duh mitteilen möchtest
bezüglich der ethik im digitalen bereich
also ich denke wir müssen
berücksichtigen dass das internet eine
virtuelle realität form ist also alles
was im internet tun ist nicht eine
simulation
wir können im internet wirkliche leute
kränken wir können also kränkungen
beginn vielleicht keine physische gewalt
direkt ausüben wie man es im
der wirklichen welt sagt jetzt mal die
nicht nur virtuell ist tun können wir
können leute verletzen in psychisch und
ich glaube wir brauchen durchaus eine
ethik der digitalisierung der
digitalität die unsere virtuellen
handlungen als virtuelle realitäten
wahrnimmt weil man also häufig im
internet den eindruck gewinnt als nutzer
das ist doch gar nicht die wirklichkeit
hier spiele ich doch nur nein das
internet ist keine simulation
es ist eine andere form der realität und
was ich dort tun hat eben auch
juristische folgen im guten wie im
schlechten
und zweiter punkt den ich noch stark
machen möchte ist wir müssen auch ein
bisschen weg kommt von den bloßen in der
diskussion um die rechte taste zwei
artikel hier genannt aus der karte wir
müssen auch wie alles zwei seiten hat zu
den pflichten kommende rechte hat hat
auch pflichten
und wir müssen uns darüber klar werden
was verpflichten wir haben wenn wir
schon den turnus der rechte kommen
sollen und eine pflicht wäre in meinen
augen die pflicht medienkompetenz zu
kultivieren das ist zum beispiel ein
anderer punkt der dann auch wieder zu
einem artikel in dieser charta führt der
die digitale bildung betrifft ist es
artikel 20 und das würde ich da auch
gerne hinzufügen dass eben
medienkompetenz die bedingung ist um
überhaupt wirklich im internet agieren
zu können das ist die tugend des
internets die tugend der digitalität und
wer sich dafür interessiert kann einfach
auch diese seite digitale karte punkt eu
kommentar modus mal ein bisschen sich
die diskussion anschauen oder gerne
mitdiskutieren ich habe auch schon 2
kommentare hinterlassen
ja das finde ich auch jetzt abschließend
würde ich gern sagen dass das eigentlich
ziemlich geile sache ist dass diese
digitale karte so interaktiv und in dem
sinne auch performativ selbst digital
ist und ich denke das ist auch ein
sinnvoller weg auf einer diskussions
ebene auf eine neue ethik zu stoßen oder
zu kommen
natürlich bietet es viel raum für für
extreme und so aber
ja auf jeden fall interessant
interessantes konzept und ich bin
gespannt wie das in zukunft aussehen
wird wir stehen noch ganz am anfang alle
philosophen philosophen sind
aufgefordert sich hier an rege zu
beteiligen ja auf jeden fall also dann
bis zu einer nächsten folge vielen dank
jörg danke bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]